WANT TO TUNE THEM OUT AT THAT
POINT.
IT WILL SHOCK YOUR CONSCIENCE.
WE START TONIGHT WITH A BREAKING
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
ON HIS 18TH BIRTHDAY, GEORGE
HERBERT WALKER BUSH AND LISTED
IN THE UNITED STATES NAVY
BECOMING THE LATEST AVIATOR IN
THE NAVY.
AFTER ONE SUCH MISSION IN 1944,
HIS PLANE'S ENGINE WAS SET
ABLAZE BY ENEMY FIRE FORCING HIM
TO BAIL OUT OVER THE OCEAN.
BUSH REPORTEDLY WONDERED "WHY
HAVE I BEEN SPARED AND WHAT DID
GOD HAVE BEEN STORE FOR ME?
SUCCESSFUL IN THE OIL BUSINESS,
THE U.S. CONGRESSMAN, THE TEN
SEMESTER TO THE UNITED NATIONS
AND THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
REPUBLICAN NATIONAL COMMITTEE.
ALSO THE AMBASSADOR TO CHINA,
THE DIRECTOR OF THE CIA SERVED
EIGHT YEARS AS RONALD REAGAN'S
OIL VICE PRESIDENT AS ONE OF THE
MOST SUCCESSFUL PRESIDENCIES IN
VICTORY.
HISTORY.
GEORGE H.W. BUSH HAD ONE OF THE
MOST NOTABLE RESUMES IN THE
HISTORY OF THE U.S. BUT HIS
PERSONAL LIFE WAS EVEN MORE
IMPRESSIVE, ALONG WITH HIS
BELOVED WIFE, BARBARA, A 70 PLUS
YEARS.
HE WAS A PARENT TO SIX CHILDREN
INCLUDING FORMER PRESIDENT AND
FORMER GOVERNOR, GRANDFATHERED
TO 17    17 AND A GREAT-GRANDFAH
TO 17    17 AND A GREAT-GRANDFAR
TO 17    17 AND A GREAT-GRANDFAT
TO 17    17 AND A GREAT-GRANDFAO
EIGHT.
THROUGH IT ALL HE NEVER FORGOT
THE BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN IN THIS
COUNTRY THAT PROTECT US EVERY
SINGLE DAY AND MAKE EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE INCLUDING IN 2004 WHEN
HE SAT DOWN FOR AN INTERVIEW
WITH YOURS TRULY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT TOUCHES ME, SEAN.
I ADMIT TO LIVING IN SOMEWHAT OF
A COCOON AS A FORMER PRESIDENT,
BUT I GO MUCH OUT OF MY WAY TO
SAY HELLO TO THE POLICE AND
FIREMEN.
BUT THE ONES THAT I TALKED TO
TO, -- >> Tucker: THESE ARE
THE SAME GUYS THAT TELL ME THEY
WATCH FOX NEWS EVERY NIGHT.
>> I'M SURE IT IS.
THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT ELITIST
COUNTRY CLUB PEOPLE, THEY ARE
SAVING OUR LIVES WITH THEIR
SERVICE.
AND WHEN THEY SAY I'M HERE FOR
THE PRESIDENT, I GET VERY
EMOTIONAL.
>> OBVIOUSLY IN BOTH HIS
PERSONAL AND PROFESSIONAL LIFE,
PRESIDENT BUSH WAS ALWAYS A
GOOD, DECENT AND HONORABLE PUSH
PERSON.
EIGHT YEARS AS VICE PRESIDENT,
HE HAD TO DEAL WITH SOME OF THE
MOST CHALLENGING ISSUES IN
MODERN AMERICAN HISTORY.
HE SAW THE COLLAPSE OF THE
SOVIET UNION AFTER HIS
SUCCESSFUL STRATEGY WITH
PRESIDENT REAGAN CALLED PEACE
THROUGH STRENGTH.
HE RESPONDED IN RESPONSE TO AND
SADDAM HOSTILE ACTIONS.
AND ALONG WITH RONALD REAGAN,
GEORGE H.W. BUSH TOOK OVER THE
COUNTRY CREATING A MILLION NEW
JOBS.
AND, DOUBLE-DIGIT INTEREST RATES
AND INFLATION TWO AMAZING LOWS.
AND THEY INHERITED THE ECONOMY
OF JERRY CARTER.
SOME CRITICIZED HIM FROM NOT
TAKING OUT SADDAM HUSSEIN IN A
VERY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
HE WAS ALSO ATTACKED ON THE
ISSUE OF NO NEW TAX PLEDGE.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER, IT WAS THE
INFAMOUS "READ MY LIPS, NO NEW
TAX" MOMENT.
BUSH ENCOUNTERED A MEDIA THAT
WAS ACTIVELY ROOTING AGAINST
HIM, AND IT'S ONLY GOTTEN WORSE
SINCE THEN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> CAN YOU EXPLAIN HOW -- IRAN
WAS OFFICIALLY A TERRORIST STAT
STATE.
YOU MADE US HYPOCRITES IN THE
PLACE OF THE WORLD.
>> THE PRESIDENT ALSO GOT TO SEE
A SUPERMARKET CHECKOUT IN
ACTION.
>> THE BUSH CAMPAIGN HAS BEEN A
MODEL AND HOW YOU ELECT SOMEBODY
WHO, EVEN HIS FRIENDS THINK IS A
WEAK NATIONAL CANDIDATE.
>> WE FIND IT VERY STEADY WORK
HEATING UP WITH BUSH'S LIFE.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT HE
RESORTS TO WITH -- SLIGHTLY
WORRYING SKILL.
>> DURING HIS ELECTION BID,
"NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTED THAT
FAKE STORY ABOUT PRESIDENT
PRESIDENT BUSH'S SO-CALLED
AMAZEMENT.
THEY INCLUDED THIS FAKE STORY,
AND MEANWHILE THE SO-CALLED
JOURNALIST AT THE     AP COULDN'
JOURNALIST AT THE     AP COULDNT
JOURNALIST AT THE     AP COULDNH
JOURNALIST AT THE     AP COULDND
JOURNALIST AT THE     AP COULDNE
THEIR CONTEMPT.
ANOTHER FORMER PRESIDENT EVEN
PASSED AWAY QUOTING
"GEORGE H.W. BUSH, SWORD WITH
THE COALITION VICTORY OVER IRAQ
AND KUWAIT BUT THEN PLUMMETED IN
THE THROES OF A WEAK ECONOMY
THAT LED VOTERS TO TURN HIM OUT
OF OFFICE AFTER A SINGLE TERM
HAS DIED.
HE WAS 94.
THAT TWEET HAS SINCE BEEN
DELETED BUT OF COURSE THIS IS
ALL PART OF A PATTERN.
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA VICIOUSLY
ATTACKING ANY PROMINENT
REPUBLICANS ALL WHILE PROVIDING
COVER TO ALL OF THEIR FRIENDS IN
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
REAGAN WAS PORTRAYED AS A
HEARTLESS MONSTER THE EIGHT
YEARS HE WAS PRESIDENT.
GEORGE BUSH LITERALLY BASHED FOR
HIS SPEAKING STYLE AMONG OTHER
THINGS AND JOHN McCAIN
EXCORIATED THROUGHOUT THE 2008
CAMPAIGN AS RACIST OR WORSE.
MITT ROMNEY CALLED A SEXIST AND
MISOGYNIST BECAUSE HE WANTED TO
HIRE WOMEN.
APPARENTLY THESE ATTACKS ARE
JUST OBVIOUSLY COMPLETELY
DISINGENUOUS.
WHEN PEOPLE DIE AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN, YOU LIKE THEM, LIKE WE
SAW WAS SENATOR MCCAIN.
MOST OF THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA,
THEY WILL DO A 180 AFTER THEY
EXCORIATED HIM AND TREATED HIM
HORRIBLY, SEEMINGLY FORGETTING
ABOUT THE NASTY COVERAGE, A
PATTERN TO DESTROY PEOPLE'S
NAMES IN CHARACTER WHEN THEY ARE
ALIVE AND THEN CREATE UP A
VENEER OF BIPARTISANSHIP, THEN
WE SAY NICE THINGS ABOUT
SOMEBODY WHEN THE PERSON DIES.
IT'S TRANSPARENTLY PHONY AND WE
HAVE VIDEO EVIDENCE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THEY ARE BROKEN UP AND
BREAKING THAT PLEDGE SHOWED THE
CHARACTER AND RESOLVE OF THE MAN
TO DO WHAT HE WAS PERSUADED WIT
WITH.
>> WE ARE MORNING AND IDEAL,
BECAUSE
PRESIDENT GEORGE H.W. BUSH WAS
THE LAST OF THE GREATEST
GENERATIONS.
SUCH RESPECT FOR THE POSITION,
THE INSTITUTION OF THE
PRESIDENCY.
>> BUT WHAT A SPECIAL PERSON,
WHAT A PATRIOT, WHAT A SPECIAL
PERSON TO THIS COUNTRY.
AND INCREDIBLE DECENCY.
>> Tucker: AND AN EXAMPLE,
TWO, LET'S PRAISE FORMER
PRESIDENT BUSH WITH THE MEDIA
WAS NEVER NICE TO COME UP MAYBE
WE COULD USE THAT TO BLUDGEON
TRUMP.
AND WHEN THE DUST SETTLES
HISTORY CAN LOOK BACK ON 41 AS
AN AMERICAN HERO AND AS A
COUNTRY CALLED GEORGE H.W. BUSH,
HE ANSWERED THAT CALL.
AT THE AGE OF 18, HE ANSWERED
THE BECAUSE OF OUR NATION
BUREAUCRACY.
HE ANSWERED THE CALL AS A 41ST
PRESIDENT OF THIS COUNTRY.
HE DID IT AS A FATHER, A HUSBAND
AND NO ANSWERS ONCE AGAIN TO HIS
BELOVED BARBARA BUSH IN HEAVEN,
AFTER THEY BOTH HAD AN AMAZING
73 YEAR MARRIAGE.
OUR THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS TONIGHT
GO OUT TO THE ENTIRE BUSH
FAMILY, AND OVER THE YEARS, I
DID HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO SIT
DOWN WITH PRESIDENT BUSH.
WE WILL PLAY THAT INTERVIEW.
WE START IN FRANCE TONIGHT WHERE
TENSIONS ARE VERY HIGH AFTER
VERY VIOLENT PROTESTS AGAINST
THE FRENCH PRESIDENT EMMANUEL
MACRON ARE TAKING PLACE.
IT ALL STARTED AS A
DEMONSTRATION BY FRANCE'S YELLOW
VEST MOVEMENT AGAINST THE
COUNTRY'S CRIPPLING GAS TAX.
THIS COMES AS GAS PRICES IN
PARIS ARE ALREADY OVER $7 PER
GALLON, WHICH IS REALLY INSANE.
SO FAR ACROSS FRANCE, THOSE
PROTESTS HAVE LEFT THREE DEAD
AND HUNDREDS OF WOUNDED AND AS
IT TURNS OUT, SOCIALISM AND HIGH
TAXES AND GOVERNMENT ENFORCED
CLAIMANT SHAMING DIDN'T EXACTLY
LEAD TO SOCIETAL EUPHORIA.
INSTEAD OF PUSHING A MASSIVE
CLIMATE CHANGE AGENDA, THAT ONLY
PUTS A BIGGER BURDEN ON WHO?
THE LOWER AND WORKING-CLASS
PEOPLE OF FRANCE AND ANYWHERE
ELSE THAT USED IT.
WHILE NO ONE SUPPORTS VIOLENCE
AND DESTRUCTION, SHOULD WE BE
SURPRISED?
IT SERVES AS AN IMPORTANT
WARNING TO ANYONE HERE IN THE
U.S.
ALSO NEW TO THE ELEMENTS TONIGHT
AS IT RELATES TO THE COMEY
WITCH HUNT.
ROBERT MUELLER IS TYING UP LOOSE
ENDS IN A PROBE AND THAT
APPEARED AS HE SAYS TO BE COMING
TO A CLOSE.
72-YEAR-OLD JEROME CORSI FILED A
CRIMINAL COMPLAINT AGAINST THE
ALLEGED COUNSEL ALLEGING THAT
THEY SAW HIS FALSE TESTIMONY.
AND MR. CORSI EXPLAINED TO THE
SHOW HE REJECTED A PLEA DEAL,
AND HE THREATENED WITH WHAT
COULD BE OF A LIFE SENTENCE IN
JAIL.
THIS IS THE OPPOSITE OF HOW OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM IS SUPPOSED TO
WORK.
AND THEN FINDING PERPETRATORS,
NOT THE OTHER WAY AROUND.
GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS PLED GUILTY
TO PROCESS CRIMES AS A RESULT OF
THE INVESTIGATION ITSELF,
NOTHING TO DEAL WITH THE
INVESTIGATION.
PAUL MANAFORT IS GUILTY ON SOME
COUNTS AND PLED GUILTY TO CRIMES
ON LOAN APPLICATIONS AND TAX
ISSUES GOING BACK THROUGH 2007.
TAKING PLACE WEIGHED BEFORE HE
JOINED THE CAMPAIGN.
AND OF COURSE THEM USING DIRTY
PONY CAMPAIGN RESEARCH THAT
HILLARY PAID FOR AT RUSSIA'S,
THEY ARE DELEGITIMIZING THIS.
ALSO, THEY ARE SITTING WITH A
PRIVATE DEPOSITION AFTER TRYING
TO FORCE A PUBLIC HEARING.
THE CLINTON INVESTIGATION WASN'T
WRITTEN BEFORE SHE WAS
INTERVIEWED, BUT THAT WAS ALIVE.
APPARENTLY WE DON'T HAVE EQUAL
APPLICATION OF OUR LAWS.
CERTAINLY MAYBE EVEN A THIRD
SYSTEM FOR THE CLINTONS
ENTIRELY.
BY THE WAY, THANKFULLY TONIGHT
IT MIGHT BE CLOSING TIME FOR THE
CLINTONS, SHADY AND ONCE
LUCRATIVE BUSINESS OF TURNING
POLITICAL ACCESS INTO HARD COLD
CASH, ACCORDING TO LONGTIME
"NEW YORK TIMES" COLUMNIST,
MAUREEN DOWD.
A RECENT JOINT SPEECH BY BILL
AND HILLARY CLINTON WAS PRETTY
DISAPPOINTING AT BEST.
SHE WRITES "THEIR PATHOLOGICAL
NEED TO BE RELEVANT IN AMERICA
IS BELIED BY A CANADIAN ARENA
WHERE STRETCHES OF EMPTY SEATS
BEAR WITNESS TO THE PASSING OF
THEIR RELEVANCE.
EVEN IF YOU ARE SHOWING UP OR
GETTING A DISCOUNT, ACCORDING TO
A NEW REPORT.
TICKETS TO SEE BILL AND HILLARY
WERE AS LOW AS $11 IN SOME
LOCATIONS.
THE MEDIAS PASSING, YOU WILL NOT
BELIEVE HOW ONE TEACHER DECIDED
TO RUIN CHRISTMAS FOR FIVE AND
SIX YEARS OLD.
BUT FIRST WE REMEMBER THE LEGACY
OF SERVICE.
PRESIDENT GEORGE H.W. BUSH, WE
GO BACK THROUGH 2004 AND, I HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO VISIT A HEAD
OF THAT YEAR'S PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
TAKE A LOOK.
IT'S GOT TO BE HARDER TO WATCH
YOUR SON.
>> IT IS FAR WORSE WHEN THEY GO
AFTER YOUR SON, AND I WOULD SAY
UNFAIRLY, AND THEY USE TO WHEN I
WAS IN THE CROSS HAIRS AND WOULD
GET CONDEMNED AND CRITICIZED.
IT HURTS MUCH MORE WHEN IT'S
YOUR OWN SON.
AND IT'S NOT EVEN A CLOSE CALL.
>> Tucker: I THINK ABOUT MY
SON WHOSE YOUNGER THAN YOURS BUT
I WOULD THINK THAT WOULD BE
HARDER.
YOU HAVE TO GO THROUGH THIS ONE
MORE TIME.
HOW'S THAT OTHER SON OF YOURS IN
FLORIDA?
HE'S GOT A LOT OF POTENTIAL.
>> HE'S GOOD AT, OH, GOD, HE IS
GOOD.
THEY SINGLED HIM OUT AS THE
NUMBER ONE TARGET FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY NATIONALLY, NOT
JUST FOR GOVERNOR.
HE CAME AND MADE THIS THE NUMBER
ONE GOAL FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY NATIONALLY.
AND HE WON BY 14 POINTS.
>> Tucker: IN THE POLLS WERE A
LITTLE CLOSER GOING INTO THAT
ONE.
HE WON BY QUITE A MARGIN.
I GUESS THAT MADE UP
MR. McCULLOUGH A LITTLE
UNHAPPY.
YOU KNOW, YOUR SON SAID
SOMETHING THE OTHER DAY THAT
REALLY STRUCK ME.
HE DID WANT TO GO TO WASHINGTON
AND CHANGE THE TONE, AND SINCE
HE HAS BEEN THERE, I'M NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE MICHAEL
MOORE'S OR THE PUNDITS ON TV.
BUT FORMER VICE PRESIDENT
GEORGE BUSH IS SCREAMING.
TED KENNEDY REGULARLY CALLS A
PRESIDENT A LIAR.
HAVE YOU HEARD THE LEADERS OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY THAT
SHRILL?
>> I'VE HEARD THEM SHRILL AND
I'VE HEARD OF SOME OF OURS
SHRILL IN THE PAST BUT I NEVER
FELT THE CLAIMANT LIKE IT IS NO
NOW, NOR THE SHRILLNESS OF THE
POLITICAL OPPOSITION.
>> IT HURTS?
>> WELL YOU EXPECT SOME OF IT,
BUT WHEN IT'S YOUR SON AND THEY
CALL HIM A LIAR, WHEN THEY
IMPUGN HIS MOTIVES, IT HURTS A
LOT.
YOU THINK I FEEL STRONGLY ABOUT
IT, TALK TO BARBARA BUSH.
>> HE JUST TELLS ME NOT TO
WATCH.
>> I READ RECENTLY THAT SHE
WON'T READ "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
ANYMORE.
>> I'M WHINING MUCH MORE
PUBLICLY THAN HE IS TOO BECAUSE
I THINK THEY HAVE GONE TOO FAR.
I THINK THEY ARE ADVOCATES FOR
THE DEMOCRATS, I THINK THEY HAD
LOST THE OBJECTIVITY THAT THEY
DID HAVE MANY YEARS AGO, AND,
YOU HAVE PEOPLE IN THERE THAT
SMEARED GEORGE AND SLAM HIM
EVERY DAY, AND YOU SEE
SUBJECTIVITY CREEPING INTO THE
NEWS COLUMNS, IT CONCERNS ME.
>> >> Tucker: YOU EVEN COMMENTD
PUBLICLY ABOUT HIM.
>> DIVORCE, HOW CAN YOU NOT
CRITICIZE THEM?
HE IS A BELOW THE BELT GUY, AND
HE MADE SOME COMMENT THEY
UNDERSTAND AND THAT DOCUMENTARY
IS GETTING ALL KINDS OF LIBERAL
FAME THAT WE HAVE A BILLION,
$200 MILLION OUT OF THE SAUDIS
OR WE WERE ENRICHED BY THAT.
AND I DON'T WANT TO MEET HIM AND
I DON'T LIKE HIS MOVIE AND I
DON'T WANT TO SEE IT.
>> THAT'S OFFERING STRONG
OPINIONS.
THEY HAD SOME INCREDIBLY HARSH
CRITICISM OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WHERE IS BIPARTISANSHIP WHEN YOU
NEED IT MOST.
TALK ABOUT AN OBSESSION TO BRING
DOWN OUR SON, COMMANDER IN
CHIEF.
HE WAS MOTIVATED MORE BIPARTISAN
POLITICS AND NATIONAL SECURITY,
TODAY'S DEMOCRATIC LEADER,
SEEING AMERICA AS AN OCCUPIER.
IN YEARS GONE BY, FDR, JFK AND
TRUMAN, AND THE MODERN
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> I PREFER DALE MILLER ABOUT
THE SHIFT AND CHANGE, BUT HE HAS
WATCHED AND HE'S WORKED WITH
THEM, HIS OWN PARTY.
AS REAGAN SAID, THE PARTY LEFT
HIM, THAT'S WHAT REAGAN SAID
ABOUT THE DEMOCRATS.
>> YOU WERE INVOLVED IN A
REVOLUTION.
WHEN PRESIDENT REAGAN AND, WHEN
YOU ARE VICE PRESIDENT AND YOU
PROPOSED YOUR ECONOMIC PLAN AND
YOU WERE GOING TO CUT TAXES, A
LOT OF PEOPLE PREDICTED THAT
DEPRESSION WOULD ENSUE.
YOU HAD THE LONGEST PERIOD OF
PEACETIME ECONOMIC GROWTH, AND
WHAT PRESIDENT REAGAN CALLED THE
GAP OF VULNERABILITY, AND
CONFRONT THE EVIL EMPIRE.
BUT WE KNOW WHAT HAPPENED, THE
WALL CAME TUMBLING DOWN.
THERE WAS A LOT OF CRITICISM.
IS IT SIMILAR?
>> I THINK THERE IS SOME
SIMILARITY.
MY FRIEND        FRIEND TED, WEH
MY FRIEND        FRIEND TED, WEE
MY FRIEND        FRIEND TED, WEY
PERSONAL RELATIONSHIP, I DON'T
WANT, ACT LIKE IT ONE BIT.
AND HE KNOWS THAT.
AND I ADMIT TO A LIVING IN
SOMEWHAT OF A COCOON AS A FORMER
PRESIDENT.
WHEN I GO OUT OF MY WAY TO SAY
HIGH TO THESE POLICEMEN AND
FIREMEN, I TELL YOU, THE ONES
THAT I TALKED TO WERE FEARSOME.
ONE FLIPPED UP THE TOP OF HIS
LAPEL LIKE THAT.
>> THEY TELL ME THAT THEY WATCH
FOX NEWS EVERY NIGHT.
>> I'M SURE THEY DO.
BUT THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT ELITIST
COUNTRY CLUB PEOPLE, THEY ARE
SAVING THEIR PEOPLE'S LIVES.
>> IT'S NOT ABOUT LEGACY.
IT'S ABOUT DUTY AND IT'S ABOUT
HONOR AND IT'S ABOUT SERVICE.
>> ISN'T SOMETHING YOU AND THE
PRESIDENT TALK ABOUT?
>> NO, BUT I DON'T NEED TO TALK
TO HIM, I KNOW WHAT MOTIVATES
HIM OVER HIS LIFETIME.
I'M JUST SAYING AT THIS STAGE IN
MY LIFE, THAT MATTERS.
SERVICE, DUTY, HONOR, COUNTRY.
POINTS OF LIFE AND FAMILY.
AND IN MY CASE WITH OUR TWO
PUBLIC FIGURES, IT'S A PRETTY
EASY FIT.
>> AND YOU ARE PROUD OF THEM AND
USE THAT YOU THINK YOU WIN
SUBSTANTIALLY?
>> I HONESTLY BELIEVE IT.
I THOUGHT I WOULD WIN.
BUT LOOK AT IT THIS WAY, THE
LORD WORKS IN MYSTERIOUS WAYS,
AND IF I WOULD HAVE ONE, I DOUBT
THAT THE PRESIDENT WOULD HAVE
BEEN PRESIDENT TODAY, IN THE
FUTURE.